i want to just give you props the plug
talk podcast great idea the only podcast
of its kind where we interview girls and
then [ __ ] them right
so
you and your only plug talk dog porn man
you and your wife uh is this your this
you guys are officially married now
right beyonce fiance so you and your
fiance baby mama you guys just had a
baby shout out to your lady um the
podcast just long was it episode three
or four three just came out with selena
powell uh so we didn't [ __ ] her we had a
guy [ __ ] this is only fans yes
exclusive only plugtalk.com uh you go
and you you interview the person and sex
happens after yeah
is it like continuous off the interview
like is it like
the interviews like all right all right
you know that great interview and then
you just i mean i would kind of like for
it to be that scene or is it like a cut
and then it's we do a little cut because
we have to take the mics off uh because
we're like wearing different mics like
for the interview part and then we
switch to like a boom mic for the sex
part so there is like a quick break
there but i would like to have it be
totally seamless for the girl because
that'd be hard plop on top of the dick
right right seamless i think the sema
should be kind of hard yeah because no
no no no point no no pun intended no one
no point proven yeah
[Laughter]
how's that going i mean amazing we did i
honestly think we did our best scene
yesterday with this girl uh kenzie ann
who uh is like a new porn star or
whatever and we just did an interview
she was super cool interesting person my
girl was like hella into her um so it
was that was great i mean honestly the
signups are you [ __ ] uh the adriana i
can't even know how to say her last
adriana chechik her [ __ ] videos are
so [ __ ] crazy bro yeah she's like
back in the day there was like
belladonna you remember belladonna i do
belladonna was like that wild [ __ ] she
used to take like louisville slugger up
her ass like she was like yeah i
wouldn't she
[ __ ] had a shaved head she was like
back in the day she was like in the bang
bros era i'd like to call it yeah she
was like the nastiest [ __ ] alive she
would [ __ ] daytime she would have [ __ ]
anybody
she would have let yeah but but anybody
this adriana chick is like man some of
the [ __ ] she be doing is like
physically uh unhealthy like yeah that's
what i like about him he's a horny dude
and he'll keep it right you wanna know
the coincidence look at the skin
pigmentation y'all [ __ ] he's not
white for the record he's half if you're
gonna put him and his whole history of
his people in the same bucket as mine
from a totally different part of the
world that just proves how arbitrary
these racial labels are well what's your
idea
white [ __ ] tell me what the white [ __ ]
look like french and uh y'all black
skinny i'm irish and
[Laughter]
i thought you were
he said [ __ ]
oh that was great i'm a white man bro
that's what i said why